ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนที่
ครูฟ้าอ่ะวันนี้ครูพระเอกก็พูดระดับไหนคะ
ช่วงนี้เป็นชั่วโมงดี Tuner คลาสนะคะดี
love
นะคะเดี๋ยวค่อยสกรีนนะคะนัก
r.i.o.
วันนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
ค่ะวัน
พฤหัสบดีบุ้งเอกต้องจับคอมพิวเตอร์นั้น
เดี๋ยวล้มขอโทษค่ะ
ต้องไม่คชื่อภาษาไทย
ไม่เขียน
ว่าวันนั้นนะคะวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีนะคะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
20 ค่ะวันที่ 20 เดือนอะไรคะครูฟ้าเดือน
มกราคม
เดือนมกราคมปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะดีพ.ต.ต.
2565 อีพา
2556  5  6 ห้าปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2  022
ค่ะ
2022 นะคะวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีเมื่อวานนี้
วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธเมื่อค่ะวัน
นี้วันพุธนะคะวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
พุธที่
19 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธวันที่
19 นะคะวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีพรุ่งนี้
อ้วนอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันศุกร์นะคะพรุ่งนี้
วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันศุกร์ที่
21 ค่ะวันที่
21 นะคะวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีพรุ่งนี้วัน
ศุกร์เมื่อวานนี้วันพุธนะคะวันนี้ครูฟ้า
ครูเอ๋จะมีมีรูป
ก็มีรูปเล็กๆ
ลูกอะไรไม่รู้
อ่า
เป็นรูปของสัตว์สเนหาสุดแล้วลืมบอกเวลา
ไหมคะเวลาเหรอคะขอโทษค่ะเวลาตอนนี้กี่โมง
คะตอนนี้
16:00 น
26 นาทีค่ะ 5
4:26 นาทีเราพูดพูด 30 นาทีก็จะเป็น
ถึงเราจะพูดถึงกี่โมงคะถึงปีกอง 50
50 เท่าไหร่ 56 โอเคนะโอเคจะเละ
30 นาที
04:56 นะคะทีนี้วันนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้ากูเอง
จะมีรูปสัตว์
[เพลง]
ต่อไปไม่รู้เอ้าไม่บอกกูฟ้าเหรอคะไม่บอก
ค่ะปลาเป็นสัตว์ไหมคะครูฟ้าปลาเป็นสัตว์
ถ้าเป็นสัตว์มีอะไรงูเป็นสัตว์ไหมคะงู
เป็นสัตว์ค่ะเคเป็นสัตว์นะคะช้างช้าง
[เพลง]
เป็นสัตว์ไปคะ
ช้างเป็นสัตว์ค่ะอ่ะสาบนะคะครูเอ๋มีรูป
สัตว์อ่ะแปลครูเอมั้ยบอกครูฟ้ารูปสัตว์
อะไรแล้วก็ครูเอ๋นะจะมีตัดเล็กๆอาจจะตัด
ก็มิ
อาจจะเป็นงูแล้วตัดขา / นะคะขนานงูมาอ่ะ
นะอาสากูดูนะกูฟ้าก็คิด
การอะไรนะคะสัตว์อะไร
แล้วก็อันที่ 1 นะภูพระคิดสัตว์อ่ะอะไร
คิดว่าสัตว์อะไรนะคะ
เล่าอ่ะผง 2 คิดว่าเอ๊ยตรงเนี้ย
เป็นอะไรของสัตว์นะคะยังไงอะไรของสัดส่วน
ไหนอ่ะใช่ไหมคะกูฟ้าต้องคิดสัตว์อะไรนะ
ฮ่าๆรูปนี้เอาอันนี้ก่อนครูฟ้าคิดว่าเป็น
อะไร
เป็นเป็น / อาหนูเป็นหัวเป็นจมูก
เป็นขานะคะเป็นแขนนี่คือ
ราคาได้ว่ามีตัวด้วยรู้ว่า
โอเคแล้วก็คิดว่าสัตว์อะไรอะนี้อะที่ 2
แล้วก็ที่ 3 สัตว์กำลังทำอะไร
ปกติสัตว์กำลังทำอะไรกิน
ไม่รู้แต่ยังงูเนี่ยงูก็เลื้อยใช่ไหมคะกู
เลยงงกินหรือหนูนอน
เห้อ ok นะเดี๋ยวเคค่ะเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋จะให้
ดูคู่เอกสต๊อกสกรีนอันนี้ก่อนนะคะได้ค่ะ
โอเค
เดี๋ยวกูเองกูเอ
วันนี้ครูเอ๋ใช้เทคโนโลยีปุ๋ยเคมี
PowerPoint หรอมีพาวเวอร์พอยต์กูเองไม่
ได้ทำเอง
ให้แม่ก็ 1
นายค่ะไม่ได้สีขาวหมดเลยอ้าๆต้องสีขาว
ก่อนครูฟ้าจะได้ไม่เห็น
หน้าไม่งั้นเดี๋ยวกูฟ้าเห็นนะกูฟ้าเห็น
แล้วเดี๋ยวกูเอ๋
เอากูฟังไม่ตรงนี้
ตรงนี้โอเคนะอยากคู๋ทำได้ไหม
อะคุยลอง 5
โอเค
สีส้มนะฮะสีส้มตื่นเต้นนะ
ครูเอ๋ใช้เทคโนโลยีครั้งที่ไหน
สวยโอเคโอเค
กูเองไม่ได้ทำเอง
ได้เลยโอเคอ้าครูฟ้า
ส่วนเป็นส่วนไหนของสัตว์อ่ะก็เป็นส่วนไหน
ของสัตว์มีเวลาไม่คุยไม่เป็นไรเรามีเวลา
เนี่ย 30 นาที
เยอะมาก 30 นาที
มึงอ่ากินใต้อ่ะเป็นส่วนไหนตัวเอกจากอยาก
มีซอยไหมคะอาทิตย์เนี้ยอันนี้คิดออกค่ะ
ส่วนไหนคะ
คิดว่าเป็นหางหาราคา
อาหาร
หากหาง
ๆโอเค
เย้เก่งมากได้ไปนึงค่ะนาง 1 คะแนนค่ะวัน
นี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะได้ละทีคะแนนน่ะที่
นี่คะแล้ว
รู้ฟ้าคิดว่าสัตว์ตัวนี้เป็น
หัวหน้ากู้ไฟล์คิดว่าสัตว์ตัวนี้เป็น
ให้ลิงไม่ใช่แมว
ไม่ใช่ปลา
ไม่ใช่ปลาค่ะอ่าเป็นนกไม่ใช่นกลูกค้าคิด
ว่าเป็นอะไร
เป็นเสือเพลงเอาเป็นเสือรู้ไหมว่าเสือ
อะไรคะเสือชีต้า
ไอคิวดีมาก Google
รู้ว่าเป็นหางหางของเสือแล้วก็เสือ
ชีต้าร์โอเคงานสุดท้ายนะครูฟ้าจะได้อีก 2
คะแนนทั้งหมดจะ 4 คะแนนนะคะอ่ะเสือ
ตีสิบล่ากำลังทำอะไรคะ
เสือชีต้าร์ฮ่าๆไม่เอาถ้าไม่เอา Choice
ได้ 2 คะแนนเลยครูฟ้าตอบได้
ตามครั้ง
ครั้งไม่เอา Choice อ่ะเอาหน่อย No  soy
นะไม่เอาหอย 5 ลูกค้าคิด
เสือชีต้ากำลังทำอะไร
เพื่อชีต้ากำลังเดินกรรมรักเดิน
เดินๆ
ๆ
ถูกไหมซึ่งต้องแอดจริงต้องแอดนักเรียนนัก
เรียนช่วยครูฟ้าคิดเสือชีต้ากำลังทำอะไร
นักเรียนได้สามครั้งนะคะอันนี้ 3 ครั้ง
อ่าครั้งที่ 1 ให้เวลานักเรียนคิดเสือ
ชีต้ากำลังทำอะไร
ครูสำหรับเสือชีต้ากำลังเดินเดินเดินๆ
นักเรียนคอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะเสือชีว่าทำ
อะไรติดต่อติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อก
2  1 แต่
กูฟ้าร้องไห้
เสียชีวิตฟ้าตอบได้ครั้งที่ 2 ค่ะ
เสือชีต้ากำลังกินเหลือชีต้ากำลัง
กินหญ้ากำลังกิน
เสือที่บ้านกำลังกินใช่ไหมอ่านักเรียนต่อ
ไปคะคันที่สองเสือชีต้ากำลังกินกำลังจะ
ออกก็กลับติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อก
321  and
ไม่ใช่เผื่อกีต้าร์ไม่เสือชีตาห์ไม่ใช่
กำลังกินไม่ไม่เดินไม่กินเสือชีต้าร์ทำ
อะไรอีกเสือขี้ตั๊กกำลังวิ่งหนี
เสือชีต้ากำลังวิ่ง
ใช่ไว้ใช่ไหมใช่มั้ย a ครั้งที่ 1 ตอบว่า
กำลังเดินไม่ใช่ฉันที่ 2 ตอบว่ากำลังกิน
ไม่ใช่ครั้งที่ 3 ตอบว่าอะไรนะคะวิ่งวิ่ง
ใช่มั้ยฮะฮะดูค่ะชิต้องทำอะไรทำอะไรทำ
อะไรทั้งสอง
แม่เสือชีต้า
[เพลง]
กำลังวิ่งถ้าคู่ฟ้า
เองมากไปสิคะแนนที่
ตาวิ่งนักเรียนถูกไหมคะนักเรียนถูกมั้ยนะ
เมื่อคืนถูกมั้ยก็มีได้นะฮะค่ะอ่ะกูฟ้า
เสือชีต้าร์เนี่ยอ่ะเสียงได้เนาะสิทธิตัน
วิ่งเร็วๆเร็วๆยาอยู่เร็วที่สุดมั้ยใช่ๆ
วิ่งเรดบุ๊ค
ตัวผอมใช่มั้ยแล้วก็วิ่งเร็วครูคิดวิ่ง
เร็วไหมคะอุ้ยครูฟาวิ่งเร็วค่ะนี่เร็วรู้
เพจชอบวิ่งไปคะฟ้าถ้าป๊าไม่ชอบวิ่งผมไม่
ชอบวิ่งแต่ว่าเร็วให้เราก็มีเสือชีต้าร์
อยู่
เสือ 15 ของครูบาน่ารักเสือศิษย์ของครู
ฟ้าวิ่งได้ไหมคะวิ่งไม่ได้กูฟ้าทำไมมัน
เหมือนแค่นี้แบ
เป็นชีต้าร์ดูสิมีลาย
เป็นเสือชีต้าร์คือเป็นตุ๊กตาเสือฉีดปลา
นะคะที่รักเธอ
วิ่งไม่ได้เสือชีต้าร์เรากินเสือชีต้าร์
ไหมคุยไม่ๆเราไม่กินเสือชีต้าดาเสือ
ชีต้าร์บางทีกินเราเนาะ
กลัวกลัวนะกลัวนะ
สวยมีฮะ
ชอบสกดติดตามอ่ะคะไทยอภัยชอบเสือชีต้าร์
เอกก็ชอบเสือ
กีต้าร์หรออ้าวเสือชีต้าร์เสือเบงกอล
คูเอกชอบเสือมาร้านนา OK เดี๋ยวดูรูปต่อ
ไปนะคะถูกป๋าได้สีเขียวลูกอยู่ไหน
สีเขียวโอ๊ะ
รู้ฟ้า
ส่วนไหนของสัตว์คะ
ติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อก
คิดมาคิดว่า
ตอบได้ 3 ครั้งหลังๆๆๆสั่งครั้งได้
ดูฟ้าคิดว่าเป็นส่วนหูส่วนหู
มี
ส่วนหูให้ไม่ใช่ใช่ไม่ใช่ถูกผิดถูกผิด
ถูกค่ะ
[เพลง]
ส่วนไหนส่วนไหนกูบาร์คิดอ่ะกูฟ้าคิดว่า
เอาหินไหมเอาหินไหมไม่เอา
ค่ะผิดน่ะ
ไม่ใช่หูไม่ใช่หูฟ้าคิดว่าเป็นตัวน
ตัวไหนหาง
หาง
หากฮ่าๆไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่หางไม่ใช่หางใหญ่ที่
สุด
ส่วนที่ใหญ่ที่สุด
ตัวหรอตัว
ก็
ต้อง
ดูว่าอะไรเป็นส่วนหนึ่งของตัว
ฝาเป็นส่วนตัวตัว
ด้วงครูฟ้า
แล้วครูครูฟ้าคิดว่าค่ะตัดตัวนี้เป็นอะไร
งั้น
ป๊าคิดว่า
สตูนี้คือ
ลิงลิงหรอหรอลิงอ่ะ
ให้ไม่ใช่ใช่ไม่ใช่ติ๊กต๊อกไปจับอ่า
นิดหน่อยอ้าวหน่อย
อ่ะอะ
อัดช่วยไหมให้ช่วยไหมมันยากหรอกใกล้ๆดิขอ
ให้คล้ายลิง
อาหารถอยลิงให้คล้ายนิล King  Kong คิง
อ๋องก็เป็นลิง
จริงคลองเป็นลิงชิมแปนซีเป็นลิงนอนก็เป็น
ลิงปริงอันเนี้ยค่อยๆลิงแต่ไม่พูดลิง
อะไรๆ
ใครๆลิงไม่พูดลิงไม่ไม่ไม่เรียกว่าลิงไม่
มีชื่อว่าลิงอ่ามิสองคำพูด
2 พยางค์
เดี๋ยว
AI คล้ายๆลิงสปีชีเดียวกันเหรอ
เอาเสียงไหมคะอยากได้ยินเสียงไหม
จะรู้ไหมอ่ะเธอยินเสียงแค่ลิงร้อง
อันนี้ไม่ร้องไม่ร้องเหมือน
มีสิ่ง
ฉันมีหรอ
กูอยากมาก
ใช่แค่นี้วันนี้ไม่ใช่ลิงเหรอคะนี่ไม่ใช่
ลิงฮัลโหลอันนี้เป็นชะนีลิงเป็นลิง
อันเนี้ยสระนี้นั่งศนีอาครูฟ้า
ชะนีกำลังทำอะไร
ชะนี
ชะนีกะมีคำ
ครูไฟล์คิดว่า
ชะนีกำลัง
กำลังทำอะไร
ตีนต้นไม้ติดปีนะตีน
ตีนต้นหมาก 3 ใครนะอ่า
กำลังปีนเริ่มต้นไม้
เดี๋ยวปีนะพี่ต้นไม้แล้วก็เปรี้ยงอื่นๆ
อ่า
ค่ะ
ฉันนี่ 2 วันนี้กำลังทำอะไรคะ
เกาะต้นไม้เกาะ
ไม่ปีนเอาไม่ปีณเกาะแล้วเกาะไว้นะอ่า
ของกูฟ้าคือเกาะได้อยู่เฉยๆใช่ไหมคะเกาะ
ใช่ค่ะ 5 โอเคแค่นี้กำลังเจาะต้นไม้
ใกล้ๆเกาะแต่ยังไม่ใช่อ่ะ
ยังไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ปีนชะนีไม่ได้ปีนต้นไม้
ชนิดนี้ไม่ได้เกาะต้นไม้ชะนีกำลังทำอะไร
กำลังทำอะไรเฮ้อเสือชะนี้กำลัง
โหร
เก่งมากภาษาไทยยากมากตอนนี้กำลังโขนต้น
ไม้
โค่นต้นไม้ 5 ชนิดนี้กำลังโหรนะคะโพสต์
นี่ค่ะ
กำลังโหรน้องมะม่วงสิ่งนี้ไปกิ่งนู้นใช่
ไหมจากที่นี่ไปนะไปที่นี่ไปที่นู่นนะคะ
อันนี้นักเรียนอ่ะเดี๋ยวนะคะคุยกันนี่ได้
งะกำลังมือหนักเกาะ
เขาได้ตกจับๆจับกิ่งไม้นะคะค่ะก็จับอีก
ไม้แต่เขากำลังจับแล้วก็โขนเดี๋ยวก็จะ
โค่นต้นไม้ไปเอง
เปิดฝาเห็นคือตรงนี้ใช่อ่ะ
ทิปตัวนะตัวเป็นส่วนของตั๋วนะคะนี้เรียก
ว่าชะนีนะคะออกเหมือนลิงแต่ข้างหน้าน่าจะ
มีขน
ที่มีสีนะบางทีสีสีขาวมันที 4 เข้าขาวๆ
บางต้องการ์ดสีสีดำๆมาคิดว่าเป็นปีที
เดียวกับลิง
ใครๆกันไปขายกันแต่ร้องไม่เหมือนกันเนาะ
ค่ะอันนี้เรียกว่าชะนีฉันนี่คล้ายๆลิงนะ
คะโอเคนะ
อีกหนึ่งภาพเดี๋ยวครูเดี๋ยวหมดเวลาได้ค่ะ
อันนี้สีอะไรเนี่ยนดูสิเทาสีม่วงสีเทาเขา
อาฮักรู้ฟ้าส่วนไหนของสัตว์ค่ะ
ตาสัตว์ตาราคาตาอาอาสัตว์ตัวนี้คืออะไร
ตัวนี้คือคือ
อะไรคืออะไรจระเข้
ไม่ต้องมีชิ้น
อยู่ดีมาก
จองแค่ปิ๊งมากโอเคจระเข้กำลังทำอะไรคะ
จระเข้กำลังกำลังนั่ง
ไหว้น้ำว่ายน้ำไหม
ว่ายน้ำนะคะอ่ะอ่ะอ้าวๆน้าอีกหรอ
ใช่ไม่ใช่ถูกไม่ถูกถูกผิดถูกผิดโอ้วกูฟ้า
ขอโทษค่ะติดค่ะจระเข้ไม่ว่ายน้ำจระเข้
ไม่ว่ายน้ำจระเข้กำลังทำอะไรตอบครั้งที่ 2
จระเข้กำลังกำลังทำอะไร
ยืน
ขาสั้นๆ
จระเข้กำลังเอาไว้ได้รีบยืน Accord คลาน
จระเข้นะมีใครลานมีนอนนะอ้า r&d อะว่าย
น้ำ
มี
นอนแล้วอยู่หน้าปาก
น้อง
ก็ระเข้ทำอะไรคะ
คลานคลาน
ร้านเมื่อกี้เมื่อกี้ว่ายน้ำใช่ไหมชาว
คลาน
จระเข้กำลังนอนหนอนและครูฟ้าเคยเห็น
จระเข้นอนใช่ไหมเวลาจระเข้นอนนอน
ทำอะไรคะ
นอน
ลืมตาตา
อากู๋ฟ้า
50% น่ะ
50% นอนอ้าปากไงโอเคนอนอ้าปากถูกผ้า
ๆๆ
แต่ถ้าเห็นไหมเคโร๊ะหากำลังนอนแล้วก็นอน
อ้าปากอันนี้ไม่ได้คลานนะคะเวลาจระเข้ up
อาจสารทิศนอน
นอนทำไมนอนอ้าปาก
นั่นน่ะสิ
กู on ลืมตาด้วยลืมตาแล้วก็อ้าปากบางทีก็
หลับตาบางทีก็ลำตาจระเข้นอนหลับตาแล้วก็
อ้าป่ะนะคะเป็นนิสัยจระเข้
[เพลง]
จะมาใข้ชอบนอนแบบนี้นะคะโอเคได้ยินเข้า
ไหมหมดแล้วภาพน้องกดให้นักเรียนดูอันนี้
ตรงเนี้ยดูจระเข้
อะไรคุยตรงไหนอ่าตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะพี่เพียร
ในเขตตรงนี้ส่วนหนี้ที่เอาให้ครูปาทาย
เป็นตาตาของจระเข้ค่ะวันพรุ่งนี้เป็นอ่า
ฮะปากของจระเข้ตรงนี้เป็นอะไรคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เป็นปัญหาฟันจระเข้อาฟันแบบฟันที่แหลม
เราพูดว่าอะไรนะคะเขี้ยวค่ะเขี้ยวนะคะ
เขี้ยวเงาก็อันนี้เป็นขานะคะเราไม่เรียก
มือเหรอ
สมาชิกไม่มีมือจะไปกินมึงปิดมึงอ่ะเดี๋ยว
นะคะเดี๋ยวคู๋เราจะมีกันตรงนี้ขา
ขาจะมาใข้ส่วนตัวนี้ก็เป็น
เท้าสุภาพเท้าโอเคตีนโอเคนะคะหน้าขาว
จระเข้ตีนจระเข้นะคะแล้วก็ตรงนี้นะคะก็
เป็นตัวนะคะตัวอ่าของจระเข้ครูกบชอบ
จระเข้ไม่
ชอบไม่เศร้าไม่ชอบ Google กินจระเข้เลย
ค่ะตัวแค่กินได้หรอคะคุณเอ๋เองได้กินได้
มีคนกินจระเข้แบบครูเอ๋ไม่กินจะละนี้
พระเอกเคยกินไหมไม่ไม่ผิดเอกกลัวคนไทยกิน
จระเข้มากๆนะคะตอนที่ฮ่าฮ่าๆใช่มี
จระเข้บาร์บีคิวนะคะ
ฟิวกับ
[เพลง]
ครูเอ๋ไม่กินเนาะไม่กินแล้วก็ไม่ชอบ
หนังจระเข้
ขอหนังตรงนี่แบบเนี้ย
เอาทำกระเป๋า
กูฟ้าไม่ชอบอีก 5 วันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จัก
สัตว์ 3 ตัวนะคะส่วนตัวนี้เลยนะคะตัวนี้
ก็คือเป็นจระเข้นกนี้ครับอาเป็นจะจะรักหา
จระเข้กำลังทำอะไรคะครูฟ้าจระเข้กำลังนอน
ค่ะนอนแล้วก็อ้าปาก
จระเข้กับค่ะพระเอกการตัวที่ 2 เป็นอะไร
คะภูฟ้าชะนีมีค่ะชะนีกำลังทำอะไรคะอันนี้
กำลังหวนอ่าชะนีกำลังโหรโขนต้นไม้ใช่ไหม
คะต้นไม้
หวยแล้วก็
ค่ะตัวนี้เป็นอะไรคะสัตว์อะไรคะตัวนี้
เป็นเสือชีต้าร์ค่ะเสือฉี่บ้านกำลังทำ
อะไรคะเสือชิบ้าผมกำลังวิ่งเสือชีต้า
กำลังวิ่งนะคะวิ่ง
แต่ว่าอะไรคะผู้หญิง
หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะคุณฟ้าพูดเวลาแล้วหรอ
เรียนโครงขายถูกอีกกี่กิโฆกี่รูปกี่รูปอา
มาได้กี่คนหรอครูฟ้าได้ 12  12 คะแนน 10
กูฟ้าตอบถูกค่ะนักเรียนตอบถูกไหมคะว่า
เสือกำลังวิ่งชะนีกำลังโหร
แล้วก็จระเข้กำลังนอนแล้วก็อ้าป่านะคะอ่ะ
ถ้าตอบถูกแล้วคอมเมนต์ไว้นะคะได้ค่ะงั้น
นี้ครูเอกกับครูฟ้าขอฝันถ้า
ไม่นานมีคะ